okay so we're just gonna plot this out
full-scale so that the guys can start
building the mechanical extensions from
your arms we still have some more design
to do but this just gives them a
jumpstart on the basic scale once that
design silhouette was set in stone wired
weired loved it YouTube loved it we
loved it
legacy loved it it was time to go into
the prototyping phase and what we like
to call the prototyping phase in the
creature effects industry and this
started way back on on aliens is we do a
garbage bag test you don't literally
have to use garbage bags it just means
bringing it together the idea in three
dimensions as quickly as possible using
cheap materials just to see that it's
possible that it that it creates the
silhouette you're looking for that the
underlying mechanical approach is a
sound one when you look at what our
restrictions are because we knew that we
wanted it to be human operated as it's
cosplay and we didn't want to have to
rely on film trickery rock puppetry we
couldn't get into hydraulics and
pneumatics it had to be lightweight
it's what you can do in a traditional
suit during my research and literally at
1:39 I came upon a little organization a
little group of guys in Japan called
scale Adonis that had built a pretty
amazing you know lightweight stick
puppet character but what I was really
amazed with was how mobile it was and
what they embraced was a pantograph
technology it's basically a slave
mechanism that they were using they had
a very good idea
she lets me moving you alarm2 up tray to
the big bottom up there and it was very
you know promising that we could to make
it better
hopefulness was what's the range of
movement where did things start to crash
lots of questions because it's not a
technology that we've used before so we
had to look at there there wasn't a lot
of footage so we have to reverse
engineer try and figure out what they
probably spent months developing and
perfecting in a matter of days we all
including me question this many times
along the way but that's also part of
the fun of it you're like looking at it
going this is really really really going
to work in the real world we've got this
thing that works on a videotape but it's
not exactly what we're after are we
going to be able to make it better or
different enough that it's going to work
for our purposes so Jim come dig and
Pete Clark got together and they built
the first prototypes in a matter of two
or three days they put together a
working prototype then translated the
suit performers our movement up two or
three feet we think could determine how
far we wanted to go if you boil it all
down
it's
what we call a parallelogram mechanism
basically the what it results in is the
creatures forearm is always no matter
where it is in space is always parallel
to bruce's for our
the first parallelogram is his bicep to
the creature's bicep so when he goes
like this
the creature goes like that and that
parallelogram is on a is on a pivot so
he when he swings his arm like this
the creatures bicep does that too and
then the second and third parallelogram
are at his elbow so when he does this
the creature does this and then the
third one is is this move and it's
challenging because you get to these
points where like he'll move his arm
just a little bit too far and then the
whole thing is it kind of like frozen in
one spot and he has to he has to learn
how to get himself back out of it each
suit has its own unique challenges stuff
like this the robot suits more rigid
you've got a you've got an exoskeleton
that you're limited to move within so
there's going to be a lot more lock off
points in a more fabric driven suit you
can stretch more this is going to have
are points that I'm going to lock
against there's certain things in the
geometry that you always find out are
kind of you can't throw out you can't
cheat you can't kind of corner one in
this case was having a pivot point in
line with his shoulder because if you
don't have it in line with his shoulder
and he tries to move you're basically
then moving like three access points and
things start to bind up and bad things
start to happen yeah I don't usually
less
it was yes wait is is tremendous and
it's all above my shoulders it's
anchored to my shoulders but it's it's
very top-heavy and then I'm on stilts
well from the very GetGo having a guy up
on stilts and trying to keep the suit as
light as possible and be at that scale
was really the main challenge having
someone you know it's not like you're on
set where you get that cut and nobody
sees what's happening after the cut and
guy can take a rest and everybody can
hold his arms up so this performer has
to be in a crowd working live and having
everybody see something that could go
wrong
you know it's just it's refining the
frameworks more you know kind of
refining the materials you know refining
the performance you know it's all a big
package and you just have to balance it
all out it's kind of like wrapping a
mover coupe around you instead of you
know being outside of it performing with
it so the trick then was you have human
arms manipulating giant arms right above
it what do we do with the human arms we
can either you know minimize them Allah
lion king or state show we're just
dressing in black and they just ignore
it or we embrace it as part of a
character and dress it out like robotic
arms and that seemed the most logical
way to go so we we dressed his arms and
as small as we can get but extra
appendages so the end result is this for
our robot with synchronized movement
that's really just stunning and it's
such a cliche to say it's nothing that
we've seen before nothing that we've
done before but it's true we've never
done that before it's one to one
movement
and true mirroring which was remarkable
was really fun to watch and for Bruce
really fun to operate